ragazzi sveglia ragazzi dai tu devi fare
il video che batte nemico si divide ciao
amici io sono non lo so più però siamo
su un gioco bello allora in teoria
dovrebbe essere tipo una sorta di segua
giampiero non belle insomma non assume
una valenza e terso sai presente una
sorta di vitali di nodi è un gioco dove
devi prendere le cose a tempo io che ho
un sacco di tempo
a disposizione teoria dovrei riuscire a
prendere le cose da tempo è bellissimo
perché ci sono ste cose
ste cose qua che sono tipo due spade
laser e bellissimo non ve lo so
descrivere
mi sono sempre chiesto come sarebbe
stato entrare nel matrix oggi lo
scopriamo le sue ma aspetta un ottimo no
arros da qui e naso veramente gigantesco
un naso gigante se vuoi che lo a ciccio
finalmente mano lo chiamo con le scale
100 100
io non so cosa sia non norman play devo
battere un record mai così no però
bisogna ora cosa devo fare
ma no che è successo ma tu sei stato
bravissimo nel file del restart non so
labbra e bellissimo però in casa lizzi
no non ci credo non ci credo poco ma da
sotto
e bellissimo
bravo bravo lei
[Musica]
sbaglia facendo prendere si stia facendo
prendere il bellissimo tra ma non ho mai
giocato a ritmi del genere è assurdo 06
cose qua a destra
niente devi stare in mezzo di far
toccare prodi sposarti
no no no non avete capito cioè sta ormai
questi muri possiamo fare dei muri direi
proprio spostare non c'è io devo
imparare come se fossero dei veri muri
ma io devo spostarmi così si deve
spostare bellissimo nostre tardi hardman
subito bene
bestia
ok pensate un po troppo
[Musica]
oh mio dio è bellissima
[Applauso]
ok speranza possa anche non avere una
ragazza nella mia vita plate di no però
si sente sicura gli un'astens
no perdonami ma veramente era troppo
figo non potevano sì ecco cosa è andato
a parte gli scherzi normale per la prima
volta cioè il conto che quando sono più
cose una dopo l'altra spesso e coseno e
io dopo vedo dopo il centro lanzoni è
veramente fino alla fico incredibile un
placement come ve lo dimostriamo che non
prese nel gioco di movimento zitto di
monza c'è niente da dire se vuol dire
bellissimo ragazzi veramente giro nella
realtà ci sta un po su dati ciando il
live vaio mai numeroso fattori ok non lo
sapesse gen
direi di provare questo maceiò
festeggiato un magro finisco sta roba è
non sono ancora primario board io l'ho
sempre no cavolo mi stavo prendendo lo
mancato e qui si sbagli due tre cose di
tinti buttafuori ha bisogno mi piace un
sacco la tua immagine del profilo marco
monsurrò mai detto ma sei tu parli della
tua immagine con la dovere sempre un po
un tossico ma ha ricordato che i due la
star del collidono fra di loro e fanno
ma magari londo giorni ma che cosa
potevano provare ma sono musiche di
tante canzoni tutto giovanni si è
bellissimo protagonisti così mi sembra
tipi di saper cucinare non so perché in
questa sensazione
[Musica]
se lo facessero anche con le canzoni di
malgioglio
vorrei sono curabili con un abito in
mamma mia sono stato fatto la vuoi
mettere ci sono le canzoni private ad
uso diverso e si possono anche creare
spero che qualcuno l'abbia fatta con
cristiano malgioglio spero sul mio
bisogno veramente figo veramente caldo
giuro sto morendo posso giocare in
mutande giorni potrò mi dà fastidio
no allora amici io ho fatto questa cosa
non per il piacere del pubblico
femminile ma perché c'è veramente caldo
però l'ho fatta per il piacere di
giampiero che sta riprendendo che
essendo lì fermo sicuramente avrà un po
più di sprint nel vedermi questo che pro
le noci mannaia quanto è bello il matrix
si entra più rilassato meteorologiche
schifo che schifo la vilipesa voglio
cucinare la carne così state tante e
cipro però non so cosa si chiamava bene
con lighting
ma perché hanno messo il tasto pausa qui
che mi porta tantissima sembra che vi
sto tenendo male sì poi no no ma
edizione poi i muri sembra che tali non
in faccia orribile capito un live che
bravo
se veramente sensuale con le mutande che
gioca a beach è un momento di pausa in
tutto no
le banche sono tre secondi non ho devi
morire dall'inizio alla fine
ok
questa è l'app auto autocarri e per
questo doveva mostrare sto malissimo c'è
di giu rosso non so voglio provare a
giocarci a 70 anni voglio dire bisogna
scappare proprio ora va bene così dice
che ci arrivi a sentenza no ma perché è
successo
marco non so se hai visto ma c'è un
piccolo 4 avere una piccola crepa nel
tuo muro nuova benissimo poi è stato
bellissimo
vabbè è stato figo però cosa schietto so
chi come noi l'idea bottiglia
sono stata la bottiglia o caldo non si
fosse in casa non si passa notato next
song bene però questa extreme è roba
l'extreme ragazzi extremes terribile
proprio tecnico questo invece raisi me
la sento una sento un aroma anche
abbastanza semplice no
ma tu lo sai palex marco malinverno per
avesse normale preparare di mariana
tajani suonando le porterà solo mi sta
facendo malissimo
allora mi sto facendo male rifacciamo
stato veramente difficile ma come per
fatti male e mi sono dato una botta in
faccia
madonna e vabbè vabbè si sa che questo è
un po troppo sporco demonio che sbatti
non sapevo che non era così facile
questo ma c'è scritto level insein dove
grazie alle palle difficili ma tu hai
provate tutte
si cerca laus che ha fatto 140.000 che
maledetto drogato tra l'altro sei un
maledetto non è possibile evitare o
bisogno di una pausa schiattando prime
impressioni è bellissimo ceduto se ce
l'avessi a casa non riuscire meglio se
temi amici solo perché non solo ragazzi
voglio parlare di una cosa non so se
avete visto per bene la potenza del di
lorenzo fiero cioè sinceramente ma che
caldo arma migliore
posso posso contare le guance bro sono
due se non aver mai nip 1 e dove
bellissimo sembra ivy o proprio tutto
gli high di pietro nella cura della
situazione
sì ma anzi pietro e mostre come si
chiama il cane se non era via la nebbia
il cane di dare di ragazzi non so che
dire
ringrazio marco per avergli prestato il
vice avevi fatto provato già e avermi
fatto provare probabilmente l'esperienza
più bella della mia vita ma giuro
veramente non sono mai stato così
contento di essere in mutande vuol dire
diciamo qui i ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come al momento mi piace anche
vari ma il tic selezione questi discrete
e ci vediamo al prossimo lightsaber o
qualsiasi altra cosa sia da rex
[Musica]